i'd like to thank nyu for making me a  doctor not the type of doctor you would  want around in case of an emergency i  try not to give anyone unsolicited  advice i will however give you some life  hacks life can be heavy especially if  you try to carry it all at once decide  what is yours to hold let the rest go my  mistakes led to the best things in my  life having the world treat my love life  like a spectator sport in which i lose  every single game taught me to protect  my private life fiercely you will screw  it up sometimes when we lose things we  gain things too we will recover we will  learn from it we will grow more  resilient because of it welcome to new  york it's been waiting for you